I think audiences will
enjoy seeing more
of Mary's transformation
into wolf in this season
and equally,
more of the wolf breaking free
and the hijinx that ensue.
We show the werewolf,
and we show alot more of
the werewolf than
we did in season one.
But then there was also
the interesting reveal of yes, it's
now a pregnant werewolf
as well, too.
[Screams]
The season opens with
a nightmare sequence.
As she looks down in her
wedding dress and her stomach
just bursts open.
Umm...again, really old school
practical effects.
Which is really fun.
And we're literally....
Aaron and Colin are working
on this here.
This is the pup,
that burst out of the tummy
and attacks Gary
at the....at the wedding.
So it's the same suit
that Andrew wore in the first one,
but it's essentially a big
prosthetic silicon tummy and boobs.
And come around here,
you can see the guys are like
inserting the hair one at a time.
Just blending from the fur fabric
into the silicon.
So we see a hand stretches,
we see a face muzzle
stretching out.
Uh feet stretching.
Spine busting.
All the good stuff.
I got you pregnant
with your permission, of course.
And not when you were like this.
Never when you were a wolf.
Relationships get
more and more complex
the longer they last.
And we are definitely no longer
in the honeymoon phase.
And as things progress
they get a little bit harder
and harder for everybody involved.
Especially me,
as you can see in this episode.
[Screams]
Oh god! Oh....
[Roar]
Mary! Mary! No! No!
Adding to the romance,
adding more wolf,
adding more action,
adding more thrills,
adding more twists and turns,
adding an extra episode,
and it just seemed to
tick every box.
I was very impressed.
It's never been scarier than it is
having a child
that is either going to be
a baby or a wolf,
and everything that leads up to it
is pretty unexpected and
and pretty chaotic.